tropical moisture from the Gulf of
Mexico could make the rain works in the
Midwest and farther south a tropical
storm is developing off the coast of
Florida meteorologist Danielle Niles of
our Boston station WBZ is tracking the
storm
Danielle good morning good morning to
you so even though it's been a fairly
quiet tropical season things are
starting to heat up we have tropical
storm Florence which is out in the
Atlantic a tropical wave coming off the
coastline of Africa and yes future
Gordon here which is likely to become a
tropical storm later on today and
actually may have just updated yes live
on your screen here as a tropical storm
right now and will be moving off towards
the Gulf Coast here towards the
Mississippi and Louisiana coastline so
that is the breaking development here
tropical storm Gordon 60 mile-per-hour
winds by tomorrow night
obviously the wind will be a concern but
it's more the heavy rain and the surge
that will push those waves in those
waters into the Gulf Coast so tropical
storm warnings are in effect all the red
shaded areas here from mobile to Biloxi
down through New Orleans and over
towards the central portion of the
Louisiana coastline meanwhile it's still
all about the heat in the Northeast on
this Labor Day 95 to 102
the heat index forecast to be during the
day today from Philly to New York to
Boston and up and down the eastern
seaboard it's really all about the heat
Louisville 100 degrees what's gonna feel
like this afternoon
many spots 95 to 100 you want to take it
easy out there today that combined with
a cold front will actually spark those
additional storms in the Midwest through
the middle part of the week
Adriana Danielle thank you